[Music]
we're all excited for Teen Titans go do
the movies we've seen the trailers and
we have found some pretty mind-blowing
dark facts about the upcoming movie
watch until the end to find a pretty
mind-blowing connection to Slade Wilson
be sure to hit that notification bell to
be the first to see our latest videos
and click that thumbs up button if you
like our video here on the things
channel now check out these dark truths
behind Teen Titans go to the movies
the Green Lantern burned Ryan Reynolds
described the superhero box-office flop
the Green Lantern as a victim of
Hollywood in fact it's no secret that
the Green Lantern movie was a major
failure according to fans we all know
that Teen Titans go features immature
characters who have no problem making
fun of each other so it only makes sense
that Teen Titans go to the movies could
revel in poking fun and other superhero
movies in fact that seems to be the
whole premise of the new movie Robin
wants to have a movie made about him he
decides he will do whatever it takes to
be in the ranks of the countless other
superhero film characters so of course
they're gonna make fun of the other
superhero movies if you watch the
trailer of the movie there's a part
where they meet the Green Lantern
Starfire asks him if there was a movie
made about him
the Green Lantern responds saying that
there was a Green Lantern movie but they
don't talk about it ouch
even Deadpool poked fun at the Green
Lantern movie considering the ratings
and low box office numbers it's an easy
target it only rated at 26% on Rotten
Tomatoes in a scathing review one critic
asked just how many more of these
superheroes can we take we know that
Robin and the rest of the Teen Titans
are hoping audiences can stomach at
least one more it seems these characters
are more of the antihero like Deadpool
but we'll get to that a little later in
the video
no Wonder Woman reference in the first
official trailer for Teen Titans go to
the movies Robin addresses the audience
he talks about what makes a real hero he
says it's not about the costumes the
gadgets for the cool powers Robin says
it's about having your own
movie he says that has always been his
dream then we see star fire beast boy
cyborg and Raven dressed his Wonder
Woman
Robin looks at the rest of the gang and
asks what they're doing
cyborg replies but they're just given
the people what they want this is a
total facepalm moment for Robin who was
trying to get everyone to take his quest
for movie stardom seriously he says that
the movie is not about Wonder Woman that
it's about the Teen Titans the Teen
Titans agree that Wonder Woman inspires
people and well they don't therein lies
the dark truth the Teen Titans don't
think they're good enough so they're
trying to be like Wonder Woman we all
know how much cyborg loves Wonder Woman
this causes some major frustration for
Robin but really can you blame the Teen
Titans Wonder Woman was a major
box-office success so it only makes
sense the 15 Titans would want to be
like Wonder Woman and they look pretty
good in those Wonder Woman costumes
right Teen Titans go started as an
experiment after the original Teen
Titans series came to an end in 2006
Cartoon Network wasn't quite finished
with the characters but they weren't
quite sure what to do with it next
so they started experimenting with the
characters in a series of short animated
sequences they made a little miniseries
called New Teen Titans it featured a
silly slapstick version of the teen
superheroes that didn't take themselves
too seriously
since Young Justice toys were selling
well Cartoon Network wanted it in for a
much younger viewing audience the
network decided to go for it and invest
it in the show that we all now know as
Teen Titans go who knew it would one day
become a movie and it all started out as
an experiment while the show was a big
departure from the original 2003
versions one thing remained the same the
voice talent for the characters move to
the new show they brought back the
original voice actors from the first
Teen Titans and they continued to voice
the characters for Teen Titans go Scott
Menzel still plays the voice of Robin
Greg Cipes is still Beast Boy and in
Walsh is Starfire Carrie Peyton is
cyborg and Tara Strong is Raven okay we
admit that's more of a cool fact than a
dark truth it just goes to show that
some experiments are worth the risk
Teen Titans go continues to be a fan
favorite Jason Todd's ashes
are on Robyn's bookshelf since we're
talking about the dark truth behind the
Teen Titans go movie let's unpack a bit
from the Cartoon Network TV show it's
supposed to be silly and geared toward a
younger audience so it's pretty
surprising when they inject a bit of
dark humor in the show if they're adding
these dark references in the TV show
chances are pretty good that they'll do
the same for the movie it's no secret
that Teen Titans go likes to put Easter
eggs referring to the DC Universe in the
episodes of the show just look at the
backgrounds and you'll find countless
references to the Justice League but
there's one Easter Egg that has fans
shocked because it's so dark apparently
a reddit viewer pointed out that there's
an episode where Robin is reaching up to
a bookshelf with various Batman trophies
on it
one viewer found a pretty disturbing
trophy on the shelf right there in plain
sight is an urn with the label that
reads Robin - next to a crowbar
apparently that's from a 1988 comic
story in the story the second character
to act as Robin was brutally beaten by
the Joker with a crowbar and left to be
blown up by a bomb it was the bomb that
ended poor Robin number two but the
crowbar has become a dark symbol in the
Joker stories ever since and it sits
next to Robin number two's ashes on the
Shelf in ttg Alfred really is getting a
lot of attention in the latest official
trailer for Teen Titans go to the movies
the gang is at a movie theater watching
a preview for an upcoming film Robin is
so excited he thinks they're finally
gonna make a movie about him the preview
goes on to say that it's a story about
Batman's greatest ally and best friend
in the whole world
Robin is sure they're talking about him
and the Teen Titans are cheering but
then they zoom out from the are on the
screen to reveal the name Alfred you
know Batman's butler so what's with the
hype about Alfred the truth is he is
getting quite a bit of attention
apparently they're making a new TV show
on the cable network epics about
Batman's Butler Alfred that's right
folks
Alfred is getting his own epic origin
story
it's called pennyworth but even before
that there was a mock trailer on Funny
or Die about Alfred's origin story if
here's Michael Caine from the Dark
Knight trilogy with scenes from Oliver
Twist
so Robins not wrong to be miffed all the
attention alfred is getting while heat
seems to be getting ignored but we're
guessing there'll be a lot less potty
humor in the Alfred series than there is
in the ttg movie in the pursuit of fame
there are so many kid shows and movies
about the relentless pursuit of stardom
according to a study done at UCLA famous
the number one value communicated to
preteens on TV and in movies popular
entertainment for kids is pushing down
values like being an upstanding member
of a community while elevating the need
for fame anyone who's wanted more
followers on social media can relate to
this relentless for super viewers and
followers now there's nothing wrong with
success and the attention that comes
with it but we seem to be missing the
important fact that any worthwhile
success comes from hard work
perseverance and developing one's
talents it seems like Teen Titans go to
the movies are chasing Fame which might
not be the best message for kids unless
the Titans realize that in order to be
considered heroes they have to perform
heroic selfless acts you know instead of
shoving their faces full of burgers and
ice cream in the movie trailer to perm
in the Teen Titans because they don't
fight crime or actually save anyone so
maybe the movie is about developing
yourself instead of seeking stardom
maybe they will learn to grow up but
after seeing that giant balloon man with
wind coming out of his um maybe not Teen
Titans are evil are the Teen Titans
really the good guys I mean Superman
doesn't even think they're worthy of
being called heroes most bad guys don't
think they're the bad guys so is it
possible that the Teen Titans are really
evil now that's a dark theory worth
exploring and it's exactly what one
reddit viewer did in his post he points
out several examples to support a theory
that the Teen Titans are actually evil
the redditor illustrates that the Titans
save a middle-aged beast boy from the
man he pointed out that superheroes
don't usually end their foes life then
there was another example in the episode
opposites in that episode the Titans
were caught robbing a bank
that's pretty villain like the reddit
user also mentions the time in in and
out where the Titans invade the hive to
blow it up then there was the time in
the episode staring at the future where
cyborg and Beast Boy were in the longest
staring
ever it lasted 30 years during their
stare off everyone else grew up to
become responsible adults since cyborg
and Beast Boy didn't want to be
responsible
they built a time machine to go back to
the past they wind up creating the
apocalypse of jump city and then there
was the time they blew up parts of the
city for free pizza we can see this
redditors point they do kind of seem
like villains alternate universe reddit
user killjoy 95 has a pretty impressive
theory about the Titans killjoy 95
realized that the Titans from the newer
TV show are unaware of the past events
involving the characters from the
original show killjoy cites an example
that none of the Titans remember taro
when she returns in tdg they don't even
explain how she returned out of her
statue formed state that she was in
during the end of the original show
killjoy thinks that since the new show
is so wacky and bizarre it's most likely
because they exist in an alternate
dimension because the Titans act so
childish and unprofessional killjoy
thinks it is likely that their alternate
versions of their original counterparts
another user commented that Teen Titans
go is a Titan parody show created by the
high five to make the Titans look
foolish so watching the ttg movies will
be like watching a movie about
characters from a TV show who want to
have their own movie but that TV show is
really a parody of another TV show to
make the original characters look
foolish yeah we're a little lost -
either that or Teen Titans go is a TV
show about an alternate universe -
another TV show for the characters are
silly and wacky and make fun of other
characters in other movies and TV shows
Jade Wilson fam Theory now let's get
back to the actual movie that's why
we're here in the first place right so
there's a theory about the Titans
heavily sought after nemesis Slade
that's pretty interesting
the roundtable analyzed the trailer of
Teen Titans go to the movies and add a
coupla cool ideas about the direction
the film might take they said the entire
film is grounded in meta humor which we
already discussed but here's something
you may have missed
Slade actually has a speaking role in
the Teen Titans movie and the Titans say
they thought he was dead cool which is
an ongoing joke for the Titans but
there's a completely new character in
the film who goes by the name Jade
Wilson
that sounds a lot like Slade Wilson in
the Teen Titans go movies Jade is a film
director who rejects the Titans by
saying she only makes films about real
superheroes but if you notice her white
hair and pale skin you'd probably
already make the connection to Rose
Wilson aka ravager and daughter of Slade
Ravager has already made an appearance
in t Tango so it's possible that the
movie director Jade is Rosa's mother
which would mean that she's intimately
connected with Slade that would make her
rejection of the Titans all part of a
sinister plot to keep them invisible to
the rest of the world not to mention the
Titans are trying to get Slade to be
their arch-nemesis so whose tape we'll
just have to wait and see and that's our
examination of some dark theories and
truths behind Teen Titans go to the
movies thanks for watching the things
see you next time
[Music]